all right we've got these cloudy skies i
was whining a little bit last night
because we could not see
the lunar eclipse but boy what a
beautiful sunrise i've been snapping
some photos and sharing them on
instagram so take a look it really has
been spectacular it's a kind of a
trade-off but we also have fantastic
photographers who get out there and find
a spot to get the shot and tyler levitt
is one of those people he drove down to
nelson in southern clark county nelson's
landing and took these beautiful videos
he has some spectacular shots as well as
the video of the lunar eclipse happening
in that blood red moon you can also find
them on our website eightnewsnow.com if
you want to go see them for yourself
take a look at your leisure it was a
beautiful sight lots of 50s around the
valley this morning because we've had
the clouds overnight we just made it to
67 yesterday paramp you've been in the
low 50s as well we've got mid 40s out
there at red rock and it will be a
little warmer afternoon because we'll
have more sunshine those clouds just
kept us cooler at 67 yesterday but rain
and snow is just kind of spreading
across the western states now it's
chilly look at the 30s the 20s across
the plains the upper midwest if you're
traveling in any of these areas around
the great lakes the midwest the ohio
valley or anywhere in the northern
plains please take a nice warm coat with
you don't go unprepared because that
chill is going to settle in for the
weekend rain is working its way off the
east coast and we'll be looking at these
clouds making their way out but there
will be scattered showers so again dress
for that from seattle and portland san
francisco a little rain this morning but
they're getting rid of that as well so
these clouds move out sunshine moves in
and we'll have cool temperatures up
there at mount charleston 54
safe hiking everybody 72 in the valley
that's up five degrees from yesterday
mid 60s the normal high for this time in
november but instead we'll be into the
70s starting the weekend and close to 70
as we get into early next week another
system brings clouds on tuesday but boy
we have some
gobbles of sunshine for thanksgiving day
and mid 60s